[Music]
[Applause]
what what is this eradication
Clark Kent feared lost in the doomsday
fight is back home tonight thanks to the
keen eye of another metropolis citizen
we thought we'd lost I recognized mr.
Kent from his byline photo and brought
him home
martian manhunter sounds nothing like me
no everybody says that
hey I almost forgot Conner's all settled
he said thanks for the sweater babe oh
they're gonna eat him alive so where did
we leave off yeah you're late
right be there in a sec Oh tell Lois
I'll see your Friday Friday what is it
worlds colliding also I have to go it's
okay I understand
I'll wait up
[Music]
pancham may be gone but this was still
the boldest move we've seen from
apocalypse yet Darkseid won't stay down
for long and we can't play defense
forever then we agree we're going to
have to take this fight to his doorstep
excellent count me in
team
[Music]
okay who left the front door open
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my reign of the Superman post-credits
scene video also explains some of the
other animated movies that are coming up
this very clearly tells you what the
next movie is going to be in this
continuity but they're also adapting a
couple other really big seminal Batman
stories from the comics that you guys
will be really excited about we're still
doing the DC Universe giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Superman moment
on the video so first up they explain
how Clark Kent comes back because he's
been gone this whole time they thought
that Superman was dead but surprise
suddenly Clark Kent just disappears out
of nowhere so they have Martian
Manhunter make himself look like Clark
Kent with the beard as if he just been
wandering around this whole time ever
since doomsday killed Superman there in
the bar trying to pick up and they're
sort of foreshadowing the Lois Lane
Clark Kent relationship but if you guys
don't remember in this movie Universe
continuity ever since Justice League war
Superman has kind of been a romantic
pair with Wonder Woman so this is just
for shadowing them having some sort of
love triangle going on like she says
that she's going to be meeting with
Wonder Woman soon he says ouch worlds
collide because his potential new
girlfriend her new flame is gonna be
meeting up with his old girlfriend so
it's just like a funny awkward haha
moment he sends Conner Kent Superboy to
live with his parents Mon puck and on
the Kent farm just like they did in the
comics then he rushes off to meet with
the Justice League and they decide that
they're not gonna sit around and wait
for Darkseid to try and attack them
again so the next movie is gonna be
quote-unquote worlds collide so to speak
with them going to apocalypse so I'm
assuming whenever they decided to make
that movie they haven't officially
announced it yet it'll take place mostly
on apocalypse but the big reversal is is
as they're deciding what to do Lex
Luthor walks in in his outfit from the
Superfriends classic cartoon series and
says alright friends let's do this ready
to go there's a number of directions
they could take that Lex Luthor has been
a member of the Justice League a number
of different times in very different
types of stories but the last time he
and Superman went to apocalypse Superman
became the god of strength and Lex
Luthor got all these crazy powers
wearing this Superman looking steel type
suit sort of an amalgam of his green
warframe from the comics but painted to
look more like the John Henry irons
steel Superman suit with a Superman
symbol on his chest
Lex
they're still pretty big dirtbags so I
think this is mostly a PR play on his
part in seeking opportunity to steal
apocalyptan technology when they're
fighting dark side
[Music]
so he will try to help out but he'll
also try to pocket some special
technology while he's over there if
you're a longtime comic book fan and you
actually read reign of the Superman in
the comic book events that came after
that you probably detected the worlds
collide Easter Egg because there's a
very notable DC Comics run called worlds
collide and it was the crossover where
the DC characters crossed over with the
Dakota verse characters from the
milestone comics if you're not a big
comic book fan that's where the
character static came from most people
know who static is even if they're not a
big comic book reader but the events of
that crossover have nothing to do with
what happened in this movie or what's
happening in the next movie it was just
basically the worlds colliding because a
single regular human character served as
a conduit between them they kind of did
that with the Hank Henshaw character
serving as a conduit for Darkseid portal
into planet Earth's orbit but the big
change that they made obviously is all
the Darkseid stuff because in the
original reign of the Superman comic
it's still cyborg superman that's the
big villain Darkseid had nothing to do
with it originally hank henshaw just
wanted to blow up planet Earth and kill
Superman
he was only successful in blowing up
coast city but what that did is a drove
how Jordan Green Lantern crazy leaving
him vulnerable to parallax the soul
basically of the yellow lantern core so
it inhabited him he became known as
parallax became a big don killed most of
the Green Lantern Corps and then in an
attempt to reverse the damage to coast
city tried to change the timeline in a
big crossover event called zero hour so
reign of the Superman essentially led
into zero hour with Hal Jordan being the
big villain nothing in this movie
indicates that they're gonna do anything
like that though it just seems like it's
gonna be Justice League vs Darkseid in
the next film the big change to cyborg
superman is that he still dies in the
shuttle accident his wife dies Darkseid
makes a Faustian bargain with him to
give him a new cyborg body that's half
apocalyptic and technology like half
mother box like regular cyborg from the
Justice League is but also half
Superman's DNA so his mission to kill
Superman is still intact from the comics
storyline but the whole conduit him
having the mother box inside him that's
all brand-new stuff for this movie the
whole love triangle with Wonder Woman
the Lois Lane wasn't a thing in the
comic
either he was still with Lois came back
to her after he came back to life
the Eradicator storyline in the movie
was largely intact still a Kryptonian AI
that's dedicated to preserving
Superman's life while he's regenerating
but the reason why he goes crazy and
thinks that he's Superman is because he
accidentally copies some of Superman's
memories so he's sort of like the
terminator version of Superman he has
none of his empathy or compassion for
people and at the end of the movie the
way they defeat hank henshaw is that
science bro Superman that's right he
actually doesn't know a lot of science
figures out that he can trap hank
henshaw as consciousness or at least
transfer it out of the cyborg body using
a Sun crystal and trap him using the
Eradicator so that's what's happening
when he jams the crystal into his
forehead he's not killing him he's
basically just copying or uploading his
consciousness into the Sun crystal to
keep him trapped for as long as he can
we'll see how long that sticks because
for a long time in the comics cyborg
superman just kept coming back
eventually he takes over the Manhunters
race and becomes something of a Green
Lantern villain while also still
continuing to be a Superman villain and
wearing his face because he still has
his DNA he becomes a part of the yellow
Lantern Corps I'm hoping that at some
point they'll do an animated Sinestro
Corps war but there's so much stuff that
they have to do to lead up to that maybe
they'll start to tease that out in the
next couple of animated movies but these
upcoming titles that they've just
announced are actually pretty exciting
so they've already announced Batman hush
in Justice League versus the fatal five
if you don't know who they are they're
basically legion villains from the 30th
century so it's a Justice League story
with villains from the distant future
but there's also a brand new rumor that
just broke in the last couple of weeks
that DC is gonna do an animated version
of Batman the long Halloween
supposedly a two-part film but that's
all I've heard so far so if we get any
details about that all totally included
in the video I'll let me know in the
comments since they're already doing
these big Batman stories what other
comic book stories do you want them to
turn into an animated movie that they
have not already done there'll be more
DC Marvel Game of Thrones happening this
weekend a bunch of you have also
requested a spoiler Dragon Ball super
bro Lee movie review I've already done a
non-spoilery one you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for my
brand new Young Justice season 3 video
for that new Batman Family scene with
the new care
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]